it got ignored today you added today
20 additional candidates to the
previously used list of potential
justices it quote in the mold of scalia
thomas and
alito among them senator tom cotton
senator ted cruz
senator josh hawley people well known to
this audience
why did you want to release them and
you're also calling on joe biden to
release the names of people he would
like to appoint to the u.s supreme court
because outside of war and peace the
most important thing the president does
is select supreme court justices
and judges you know we're going to have
probably over 300 by the end of my first
term which is a record
over 300 federal judges and court of
appeals judges too
so that's a that's a number that nobody
thought even possible and
we will have that number and it'll be
all confirmed and done and
great and also supreme court judges or
justices and uh
you the whole country it depends on
these decisions which way you go
whether you have a second amendment or
not i mean the second amendment would be
under siege if i wasn't here
you wouldn't have a second amendment
right now you wouldn't have a right to
guns you would
whether you had it or it was just almost
totally obliterated
but it would be in a very different form
than you have it now i've kept it
totally as it was
and it's you know something i'm very
proud of and people
i think it's a real voting issue a
second amendment
life you look at that so these judges
are going to be making
massive decisions and the next president
is going to get one two
three or four justices of the supreme
court
i have two that's actually considered a
lot you've had many
uh ju you've had many presidents frankly
where they
didn't have i think they had none many
of them had none you know they
they stay on there a long time you don't
have many and they stay on there for a
long time so
you've had presidents with none that
have been in for a long period of time
but i've already had two and you could
have
literally anywhere from one to four
additional that changes the entire
fabric of the nation for many years you
know they're on the court for 25 30
40 years depending on the age depending
on what age you
choose and frankly most of them are
young because you want to pick young you
want them on as long as you can
have them on so uh it's a very very
important thing that's happening and
i felt that i should announce the list
and from which i will only pick
so we had 22 or 23 and now i added 20
so we have about 43 and
uh it will only be from that list that
i'll pick whether it's one two three or
four it'll only be from that list so
everyone can look at that list and
they'll be happy or not happy joe has to
put up a list
this was something that i came up with
the last election i think it might have
been
one of the reasons for my success in the
election because people weren't sure who
would i pick
and i actually put out a list of 20 and
then 25
and i said only from that list well only
from this list and the previous list
will i pick
joe has to come up now with a list he
should come up with a list otherwise
people can't vote for him
but the reason he possibly won't is
because he's going to come up with far
radical left judges i mean these will be
people that are very very far to the
left that are
you know revolutionary in a sense i
think
and he's got to come up with them i
don't know that they're going to allow
because they control him totally
they control joe biden he's not
controlled he's not in control of
himself
he's controlled by the radical left it's
a very dangerous
part of our society and he is totally
controlled and he's not going to be able
to name
democrat judges that are in the middle
someplace or normalized you know people
that are like
normal people he will be forced to pick
extremely
radical left judges and i don't think
you can get elected if you do that
if you do what he has to do which is
name the judges that he's going to pick
or the justices
soon to be that he's going to pick i
don't think it's
i don't think he'd be electable so he's
got a real problem
let me go to the issue of national
defense as president
the largest military buildup since the
reagan years
first pay raise in in many many years
for our military
uh you resolved the va hospital scandal
that existed in the biden obama years
you removed the rules of engagement
uh which allowed you to beat the
caliphate in
syria which joe and barack were not able
to do you got solimani baghdadian
associates
uh you got the al qaeda leader in yemen
and you you're pulling america out of
long protracted wars by the use of new
military technology
but the story is claiming that you
disparage for
fallen soldiers yeah it's a total lie
it's total disinformation they put it
out then they do commercials on it
and to think that nobody that i know
could have
said those things look down at soldiers
that have been dead for
uh decades and decades and decades real
heroes
and they made it up they made up the
story we have 21 people i think you
probably saw much more than that if we
wanted to because there were many people
there
and the secret service wouldn't let me
take the trip because of the
the dangers of going through very
crowded parts of a certain part of
europe as you know we're in
paris and they wouldn't let they said we
can't do it because the helicopter
couldn't fly it was raining as hard as
i've ever seen it rain it was foggy
so foggy you couldn't see anything it
was serious paris fog
and like you couldn't see anything so i
knew immediately you couldn't take the
helicopter
the drive would have been a very long
one which i would have been i had
nothing else to do i went there for that
in fact the next day i went to another
cemetery and by the way it was
pouring but not nearly as hard but it
was pouring and i made a speech in the
rain
no umbrellas know anything you know they
said it's just this information i didn't
want to get my hair wet i've had my hair
wet plenty of times
i made plenty of speeches in the rain
and if i wasn't
if i didn't you wouldn't be president
right now that i can tell you so
it's disinformation they made up a story
about two disgusting words that they say
i said
and i didn't and i have many witnesses
we have 21 witnesses they only have
sources
sources say there are no sources they
made it up it's a bad guy it's a bad
failing magazine called the atlantic
and of course the media picks it up and
then they do television commercials we
put them a notice don't do it
take it down and i've worked too hard on
the military and making it really great
again that's what we've done we've
rebuilt it was totally depleted when i
took over
it was depleted it was tired it was
exhausted from all these endless wars
where our soldiers are being brought
back because i can't stand to see them
coming back in
shape when they're not really fighting
they're really serving as
police forces over there we're not
fighting to win and they haven't fought
to win
but i knocked out isis killed solomani
killed
al-baghdadi did things that obama can't
even think about doing
when i took over isis was all over syria
was all over iraq
but i want to get out of there now we've
done it let them protect themselves and
there's plenty of countries over there
that can do it
let me ask you about the violence that
has been going on well over a hundred
days
in american cities new york uh
obviously chicago we have portland we
have seattle we have los angeles we had
kenosha three cities that did request
your help and assistance
uh dc minnesota kenosha
you were able to send in the guard they
restored order you've been begging
the the de blasio's and mayor lightfoot
and
ted wheeler and the the governor of
of i'm sorry the mayor of seattle pretty
much
begging them to allow you to help them
restore order
um joe biden had said at one point
police become the enemy
wants to reallocate funds uh kamala
harris
uh was for the reallocation on defunding
the lapd 150 million dollars you got a
billion dollars now cut from the new
york pd
uh why do you think that these mayors
and governors steadfastly refuse
uh your offered assistance to restore
order
well kenosha is a great example that was
ready to burn down
after three nights and we went in with
the national guard and just closed it
out
it took like so quick and minneapolis is
another example that was
the problem is it was burning for two
weeks before the national guard came in
and once the national guard came in it
was over it took
you saw it 45 minutes to one hour and it
was all over this was going on for weeks
and
we would do the same thing we were ready
to go into seattle they took over 20
of the city a big chunk in the middle of
the city and
they heard we told them we're coming in
and then they sent their police and
their police are fine they're good if
they
let them do what they're supposed to be
doing but they don't do that these
they're all democrat-run cities and
they're not right well
run and they're very very they become
very unsafe because
the level is so ridiculous they do want
to defund the police and i've never seen
somebody that could change like by now i
don't actually think he's aware of what
he's even saying to be honest with you
but
i've never seen anything like it where
he talks about
defunding the police or not doing much
for the police and then all of a sudden
he sees what's happening with this poll
numbers because as you see we're going
way up
i think we're leading in florida we're
leading in wisconsin we're leading in
pennsylvania we're leading in north
carolina
i think we're leading in new hampshire
we're leading by a lot and
we're really leading by a lot in ohio i
just saw a poll a little while ago i
think we're leading all over the place
frankly but
you know the fake news doesn't like to
say that i must tell you that fox has
among the worst pollsters of all i think
they're terrible i don't know who at fox
is doing it but
they're terrible pulses and they have
been frankly even four years ago that's
probably the same group but they don't
have a clue your pollsters
actually like matt towery he does he's
separate and apart
for the fox o and o's he's i've known
him since newt gingrich's
contract with american days i've gone to
him and john mclaughlin
and scott rasmussen